>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> I'll just have
you guys first start
out by introducing yourselves
and the instruments you play.
>> Noah Martinez: Hi.
My name is Noah Martinez,
and I play live --
I play bajo quinto
and quinto huapangera;
and in the studio different
acoustic bass, guitarron,
and tololoche as well.
>> Leticia Gonzales: My
name is Leticia Gonzales,
and I play violin, percussion
including a wood block
and a snare, and jarana, and I
also sing and sometimes I dance.
>> Jordan Wax: My
name's Jordan Wax.
I play the fiddle and
the piano accordion
and sometimes I play
the mandolin also
and button accordion.
I think that's it.
And I sing, yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano: I think
it will be good to first start
out by talking about the
history of Lone Pinon.
>> Noah Martinez: Yeah.
I met Jordan and another
guy we used to play
with on a Sunday morning.
There's a coffee shop in
Albuquerque called Zendo Coffee,
and I was playing -- been
playing every Sunday there
with people who play
Son Jarocho music.
And I just went in -- I was
there playing like normal
and these guys came
in, they fit the bill
of the coffee scene crowd,
handsome, hip young men.
And I didn't think much of it
because people didn't pay
attention to the music so much.
But then I saw them kind
of mouthing the words
and I thought, whoa,
that's crazy.
So I took a break.
I went outside.
And when I came in, Jordan
was tuning his violin.
And we played a few
songs, right.
>> Jordan Wax: Yeah.
>> Noah Martinez: And these
guys were really cool,
so I just invited
them back to my place
and we drank apple spiced tea
with plum and played music
for hours, like four hours.
>> Jordan Wax: Propelled
by the apple spiced tea.
>> Noah Martinez: Yeah.
That clory and raven
[phonetic] special plum sauce.
And then they had a gig on
every Wednesday in Santa Fe.
And this was on a Sunday.
And they're like, well,
we're playing Wednesday
if you want to come up.
If you come up an hour early
and we'll rehearse some tunes.
And it kind of never stopped
from there, it's
been that since.
>> Michelle Stefano: Great.
And how about -- I
don't know how to begin
with unpacking all the
rich, as I said before,
traditions that you draw upon.
But maybe just first talk
about what was the
inspiration of Lone Pinon?
What are your aims, so to speak?
>> Jordan Wax: Well, kind
of how I came to it --
I'm from Missouri
originally, and had a chance
to learn the fiddle from
older traditional fiddlers,
square dance fiddlers
there and contest fiddlers.
And I wanted -- I think that
was a cool chance to get
to experience that
way of interacting
and the intergenerational
thing and being involved
in a really regional tradition.
And I think I have that motto
when I moved to New Mexico.
And after a while I kind
of quit playing music
but I started really missing it,
and I wanted to have that kind
of relationship with
older organizations.
And so that I think having
brought that helped me kind
of know what I was looking
for and that got me interested
in finding the older New
Mexico fiddle traditions
and working with those.
So that was kind
of one inspiration.
You guys probably have
other inspirations
that brought you
in this direction.
>> Jordan Wax: Would
you like to go first?
>> Leticia Gonzales: Sure.
So I learned music through
mariachi, which is kind
of a tradition that lays
over what we're playing now.
It came after the string
band style and in a lot
of ways supplanted the string
band style in New Mexico.
So then my family
is from New Mexico
and predates the mariachi
style, they have a lot
of identification with mariachi.
So I started as a
mariachi player very young
and started playing
classical music.
I played a lot of
And have always been
interested in folk traditions.
And a few years ago,
before I met these guys
and joined Lone Pinon, I
was working a lot in sort
of the community choirs
and things like that.
I played in a gamelan
orchestra and started wondering
where that was happening in New
Mexico, why it wasn't happening
in New Mexico, if it could
happen in New Mexico.
And when I met --
I met Jordan first.
When I met Jordan, he
and the other member
of the band were playing
and I was really excited
to see young people
playing the music.
And then I met Noah later,
and was like super delighted
to hear all of what they had
going, the musical fusion.
And I think that in addition
to loving the music because I'm
from there and to loving the
community aspects of knowing how
to dance a polka, dancing
a polka with my grandfather
and my father and my
mom and all my cousins,
you know, my whole life.
To be able to generate the music
that those dances come from.
And so I feel like
my participation
in the band was a fusion
of a lot of things.
But in trying to reclaim some
of the community practices
that I had seen the last
vestiges of growing up
and was kind of wondering about.
Yeah.
>> Jordan Wax: I guess for
me I started playing music
when I was 12.
And I grew up in kind
of a rough neighborhood.
And so a lot of us kids
were kind of like getting
into trouble, starting to hang
around with the wrong crowds,
and myself included a
little, just a little.
But a friend of mine moved
back to the neighborhood
who was my best friend
from second grade.
And he had started
playing guitar.
So I kind of just jumped
on the wagon with him
and kind of kept it up.
So when I was a teenager,
my late teen years,
my neighbors played old
style ranchera music,
just acoustic guitars,
some beers, friends,
neighborhood style
in a ditch bank
under a conwood [phonetic] tree.
And they let me kind
of come and hang out.
So I always sort
of followed that.
I love blues and the
traditional music.
So there's another group
in Albuquerque called
Felix y los Gatos,
who sort of do a fusion
of blues and polka styles,
and they're from generations
of traditional musicians.
So I kind of got with them and
played with them for a few years
and really learned the
-- they're a blue-collar,
hard-core band that just
plays gigs constantly.
And then I wanted something
a little more refined,
so I've just been
chasing the traditions.
So from them, you know,
which is what led me
to me meeting Jordan.
Because I was just trying to
find the elders in the community
who played older
different styles of music.
And now it's totally -- we're
on the path together
searching and forging forward.
Because we're discovering
new music weekly,
things that we've never
heard before that --
so it's very alive right now in
that pursuit of the old ways.
>> Michelle Stefano: I'd love
to ask you about your process,
but first let's talk about
some of the traditions
that you are drawing upon.
I don't know where
you want to begin,
but maybe where you've grown up.
I know you grew up in Missouri.
But nonetheless, New Mexico?
>> Jordan Wax: Yeah.
We started with the old-school
northern New Mexico dance
repertoire, which is what
normally it's violin-based
and there's accordion,
violin and accordion
melodies for dances.
There's different dances,
like the varsoviana we played.
There's the cuna.
There's the indita, the
chotiz, valse [inaudible] --
different valses,
polka of course.
And each of those tunes
has komancha [phonetic].
Each of those dance rhythms
has a special genre of tunes
or just one particular
tune that goes with it.
So we started out just trying to
learn those, and then that kind
of lead us into other things,
probably because
people would request it
when they saw we were
playing old music.
They'd say, play
Margarita, Margarita or.
>> Noah Martinez:
Play [inaudible].
>> Jordan Wax: Yeah,
[inaudible].
And then from there
we started getting
into the huapango huasteco,
which is I think is some
of the first waltzes I was
learning in that period
of the New Mexican music,
have a little something to do
with the huapango music.
You can tell there's
some connection.
And that's the style that
comes from the Huasteca region,
which is normally played
with a quinta huapanguera
and a jarana huasteca.
Noah plays the quinta and
Leticia plays a jarana
and the violin in
the trio format.
And we also learned some
from Ken and Jeanie --
Ken Keppeler and Jeanie McLerie,
some musicians in New Mexico
that have worked with
a lot of the elders.
And they introduced us to hona
oda [phonetic] music from some
of the musicians they'd
worked with in Arizona.
And so we incorporated --
we've been doing some of that.
>> Noah Martinez: Our friend
Scott Mathis gave us a bunch
of music from [inaudible].
In the early days I remember
we had our first road gig
and we were kind of a new band.
And he gave us a stack of CDs.
We were listening
to [inaudible].
And we were all amazed
in the van.
We're like this --
we could do that.
That gets us.
That's our music right there.
>> Jordan Wax: Yeah.
You can hear, it's the
same instruments at play,
doing much more complex things,
and we were really inspired.
Like, oh, we can
do that like this.
And that kind of
helped us understand,
and we can play the New
Mexican music like that too.
We can open it up and make
it more engaging in that way.
And it helped us
diversify the palates,
because there aren't
a lot of examples
of the old New Mexico
music to have
like a real broad
representation of it.
So we kind of borrowed them
from those other things too.
>> Noah Martinez: And also
when Jordan started learning
huapango music, he got in touch
with our friend Juan Rivera
out in Chicago, who is actually
from Michoacan -- but he
plays amazing huasteco violin.
And he turned us onto a
lot of [inaudible] and kind
of the music from his land,
and that's inspired us greatly.
And our instrumentation as well.
You know, we don't use
typical instruments
for all the traditions, so
we kind of have adjusted --
or we don't have the
amount of members.
So I think that kind
of has helped us.
Where we say, okay, like we did
with Serafini Vara [phonetic],
where we go, this sounds
like something we can do,
this is what we have, and we
sort of make -- we make it fit.
So that's kind of nice.
>> Michelle Stefano: You
talk a lot about meeting
and learning from elders.
How does that come about,
just from your families,
the communities you grew up in?
Or, what is the landscape
today or these past years
in New Mexico for
traditional music?
I know that you've noted
that it is diminishing a bit
or you're tracing this history.
>> Noah Martinez: Well, a guy
who we've worked with a lot,
our buddy Thomas Mize, we
met him at a farmers market,
and he just walked up to us and
asked us if he could record us.
And we said, yeah, sure.
And he pulled out his phone
and recorded us a bit.
And then after a song,
he came and said, hey,
let me play your violin,
let me try this song out.
And oh, yeah, try this,
and then he played a melody
and went yeah, this
is this tune.
And it's just really
organic meeting people
like in life while
we're playing.
And I think a lot of the
elders appreciate that.
Where some people are on
social media and because
of the Internet and everything,
you can kind of reach
out to people and make contact.
But we have met a few people
just in just playing music too.
Jordan's studied a lot.
He went in and studied
with Serafini Vara.
Maybe you could talk
about that a little.
>> Jordan Wax: Yeah.
I tried to seek out people
to learn from and have
that connection with the music.
In New Mexico, our friend
Thomas has helped us all a lot,
and he kind of grew up --
he was kind of the youngest
of his cohort of musicians.
So he's one of the only
ones that are still playing.
And there's another guy named
Mariano Romero [phonetic],
that he played with
as a violinist,
but because of arthritis in
his shoulder he can't play.
But he still -- he came
to our dance last time,
which was really cool.
>> Noah Martinez: And
he's got a Cadillac,
and he's got his name
on the license plate.
It is awesome.
>> Jordan Wax: And then we also
still have Antonia Apodaca,
who I think she's
94 now and she lives
in an assisted living
place in Albuquerque,
and still plays great.
She gets tired sometimes
after a couple songs.
But she plays wonderful.
And I like to go
play guitar from her.
>> Michelle Stefano:
And again though,
how did you find
out about all these?
>> Jordan Wax: I found out
about -- I'd heard about her.
And she, you know, plays in
like at the Spanish market
and fiestas and stuff.
>> Noah Martinez:
She's a legend.
>> Jordan Wax: She's kind of --
yeah, she's really well
known in New Mexico.
And some friends of us --
of ours from Silver City,
Ken and Jeanie, who
are called Bayou Seco,
their group are really
accomplished
traditional musicians.
They had spent a lot of time
with her and toured with her
and came to Washington,
DC with her
and really inspired
her to keep playing.
And I had talked to
them and they said, oh,
you should just call her up
and go visit her one day.
And I kind of hadn't done
it, I was too or something.
But then one day I called her to
ask her a question or something,
and she was like, are
you coming up later?
What time will you be here?
And I was free that day
so I was like, okay,
I'll just come up now.
So I drove to Las Vegas,
New Mexico where she
was living there,
and then just started
going every week
to visit her for a while.
And now she's down
in Albuquerque.
So that's how that happened.
And then, you know, when I
got there -- she is older and,
you know, has trouble
finding people to play with
and she's really particular
about her backup
too and sensitive.
She says like if someone
plays the wrong chord,
she gets a stomachache.
So it works great
because she likes
to have someone to back her up.
And then she'll practice
because she doesn't
like to play by herself.
So that's how that happened.
>> Michelle Stefano:
So you guys are young.
How do the older
musicians and masters
of these traditions feel about?
>> Noah Martinez: At first they
didn't really like us very much.
They sort of scowled,
like who are these boys,
or who are these
children over here?
But then I think with
time, we just kept playing
and then you sort of earn their
respect just through repetition
and kind of like not going away.
And then Antonia, someone
-- like she's a master.
She accepted us pretty quickly.
Some of the other people
like don't like us.
But everyone is cool
with us now.
I mean, in the beginning it was
odd, but everything's fine now.
I mean, I feel like -- like
Ken and Jeanie, we just played
with them last week a string
shows, and we got to really bond
with them in a way
that's different.
We've gone and learned
from them at the house
and spent lots of time.
But playing next to
each other in real time,
you just develop this sense
of relationship that's
totally different.
And, you know, there's always
the super sensitive emotional
talk after the gig where our
hearts are all open still
for music, and I just had some
really kind words with Ken.
And he was like, you know,
we love you guys and the fact
that you guys really care about
tradition and are doing it,
trying to keep this going.
I think maybe that's a sentiment
that some of those people have
of us now after they
saw that, well,
maybe we're just not trying
to make a quick cash grab
with traditional music.
It's like, well, we love
this, it's really our life.
We're not doing it because
it's a trend, you know.
So I think once you
get past that,
people seem to treat
you pretty with respect.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Traditionally what are some
of the places and spaces
where one would hear
this music and dance?
>> Leticia Gonzales: So I
think there are a couple
of different layers.
I also have a background in
folklorico, so I spent a lot
of time when I was younger
like at fiestas throughout
northern New Mexico,
which are celebrations.
They're like annual -- they
coincide kind of with harvest.
But they have a longer history.
They're religious and
social celebrations
that have survived
for quite a while.
And they're in the middle of
kind of a transition right now,
so it's an interesting time
to think about the fiesta
in northern New Mexico.
And each larger like city
area has different traditions
that they follow, but
essentially it's a reenactment
of the Spaniards
coming to New Mexico.
So it's under a lot
of fire right now.
And, as it should be kind,
it's kind of being
questioned and updated.
But I heard a lot
of this music there
and I heard only
recordings played
for like a specific folk
dance group that tries
to keep doing the cuna
and the varsovienne
and these older dances,
the indita,
which comes to us from Spain.
So I don't really remember,
I probably saw Thomas
when I was really small and
I probably saw him playing.
But my primary source for
the these older recordings --
or older styles was through
recordings at fiestas.
And so I think that that became
the case during my parents'
generation or like
from the '50s onward.
And before that they were played
at like fandangoes or dances
that were done not only in like
each specific locality but even
in like specific neighborhoods.
So like the east side of
Santa Fe where my dad is
from had a fandango, and
the west side of Santa Fe
where my mom is from
-- which is, you know,
15 minutes by car --
had its own fandango.
So there were different --
you know, they danced
the styles differently
and they had different music.
But that would've
been my grandparents'
or great-grandparents' time.
So from kind of a living
fandango community dance
to a more stage sort of
representation of like,
this is what it means to
have new Mexican music
and New Mexican dance.
But most of the styles
that we play have something
to do with dance as well.
So they're not usually --
I was thinking that as we were
playing in the auditorium.
It's a little bit
special to be playing
for just a listening audience.
You know, a lot of the
accordion snare bajo stuff,
you would just be
dancing at a square
or at somebody's celebration.
So they're meant to be felt with
your body and with other people,
and there's a very lively
aspect to all of these dances.
And too with I think the
sonplaneco, huapango,
there are specific dance
styles that go with them.
So not so much in an
auditorium, very much outdoors,
very much for ritual
celebrations,
for planting celebrations,
harvest celebrations.
>> Weddings.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah,
baptisms, weddings, matanzas.
Moments when the community
comes together to celebrate
or to be in joy together.
>> I think that's kind of part
of our experience and interests
in doing this kind of
music too is kind of --
because my understanding
is that --
and when electricity
came is basically
when people started then
amplifying instruments and,
you know, electric guitar came
in and then drum set could come
because they had
louder instruments.
And about that time,
from the recordings
and from elders we've
been able to talk to,
it sounds like there's just a
brief period where they kept
up the fiddle tradition
and the old dances
with that electrified
instruments.
But then it quickly, as that
new instruments got adapted,
all the old music went
out the window kind of
and adopted new music too
that was just simpler.
You know, I mean, great
dancing but not any
of the other more
specific dances.
And so I think like
what Leticia is saying,
like that chronologically is
kind of how that played out,
that it went from being,
you know, an active part
of these celebrations to more
like something everybody
remembered and responded to
and wanted to see the dancing,
but that wasn't being
recreated, renewed.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah.
It's kind of a specialized
practice
to see these folk dances done.
So, you know, people
go specifically
to this group once a week
to learn these dances.
And part of our -- we've started
hosting bailas [phonetic]
in the last six months
or so, with the hope
that people can come and have of
an interaction with these dances
in a less like institutionalized
way.
That, you know, you don't
have to even really be able
to keep time, you
can participate
as a member of [inaudible].
Which, you know, I think
probably is true to how
that was practice in
just a community setting.
So in that way too,
to try and ground some
of our own experiences with
the music and the experiences
of those people who are getting
to hear our music and to save it
from becoming too specialized
or not for like the people.
>> The public.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah.
>> Which is --
those associations
have done a great job
of keeping those
traditions alive.
And I think now with our
generation, I think it's sort
of our duty -- we've taken on
the duty to sort of take those
and say, okay, now let's take
all the fancy stuff off of that
and we can learn and do it in
kind of the old way where --
like we did a dance with
Bayou Seco recently.
And it was amazing, you just
you don't get those moments.
I mean, even if we were
to do a show all together
on a huge stage in
front of everybody,
that would be awesome.
But to get to play one
dance tune for 15 minutes
where we're watching
the crowd and then it's
like it's totally --
it's just amazing.
And to see the people and
the interaction and the kids
and the older people
and it's like, wow,
it's really a true
sense of community.
And I think that's what
kind of the purposes is
of that, of those situations.
Like Leticia was
saying where it's
like each community had their
own dance, well, I mean,
part of that played into that
because they wouldn't mix
so much, because it's like,
well, we can do something
with our people over here on
this side of town, have fun.
You know what I mean?
Everyone's going to be there.
It's great.
The dance is sort of secondary
to the social get together .
So yeah, we're sort
of in the middle
of bringing that back around.
>> And that's how
we approach a lot
of the music too is
figuring out, well,
this is how it worked before,
and obviously it's
not working anymore.
But we have all the
pieces and we're, you know,
we understand somewhat
what life is like now.
And we're as qualified as
anybody to try to figure
out what it might take for it
to get some new life again.
And you know, not just
in a sense of performance
or recordings, but in the
sense of the community
and for actually -- you
know, for the tradition
to have life and be renewed.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah.
I think as Noah was saying,
these kind of institutions
or organizations have done
a good job of preserving.
So there's a lot of New Mexican
culture that has been preserved.
You know, we work with archives,
the One Beat IL Archive
and the John Donald Rob Archive
at the University of New Mexico.
And we an amazing amount
of source recordings.
So we might not have
those elders anymore,
but we have their recordings,
and we also have
video of dances.
We have costumes that have
been, you know, preserved.
But the idea of preservation
I hope is to be revitalizing
and to be re-introduced.
And so, you know, New Mexico
being such an interesting
and complicated place,
and in a lot
of ways remembering what it was
like to be itself
before electricity.
I have stories of my dad,
you know, not ever getting
to use a shower until high
school, which was in the '60s .
They had no running water and
they had no electricity, yeah,
in the house that I live
in now, until the '60s.
Which is an important thing for
everybody to just take a minute
and think like, wow,
a generation ago,
in parts of our country,
there was no running water
and people lived
and they made things
and they had traditions
and culture.
>> Beautiful lives too.
>> Leticia Gonzales: You
know, that in addition
to preserving it, that we
try and find a way to marry
that to what's, you know,
our particular challenges
in this time right now.
Growing isolation.
I mean, I see a lot of -- a lot
of my elders I knew kind of like
at a remove, you know.
We were no longer able
to care for them at home
and to give them good lives
at home in their older years.
And so trying to not
only preserve the dances
and preserve the music but to
preserve the sense of, well,
you know, I see you at dances.
I've danced with you.
I know what it's like
to dance with you.
I've prepared food for you.
You've prepared food for me.
And to remember what it's
like to be human together
in a community within the
wider sort of global idea
of the world in which we live.
So for me, I think
that that's a big piece
of what this music is about.
That it is, we're
musicians, so we do the music.
We're artists, so
we focus on the art.
But if I was, you
know, a social worker,
I would be doing similar
hopefully initiatives to try
and bring these values and
the ability to be human
with each other to
individuals and hopefully also
to a larger community level.
>> Michelle Stefano:
You remind me --
you wrote about the many
traditions that you draw upon,
that they represent
radicalism, creativity,
and cross-cultural solidarity.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
>> Noah Martinez: I
actually don't know what any
of those words mean.
No, I'm just kidding.
Yeah, I think that's it.
I think to be radical is
to be different then what
society wants to be, right.
Like so for us it's the main --
like Leticia was saying about
that connection you have
with an elder, and you
see each other as like,
we're all in a circle, right.
So a lot of times
you're in that circle
and the older people
are looking down on you
because you're just the
young kid, then we grow.
And then we -- a lot of
times elders get forgotten
that there was a whole life that
was lived and all these lessons.
So we sort of look at
them in a down way.
But when you get to that point
where we're looking eye to eye,
that's really the awesome part.
But it takes you a little bit to
-- it takes a while to get that.
And that idea is radical.
I think it's -- you know,
it's like, well, look at us.
We're obviously young people.
We shouldn't necessarily
want to be hanging
out with older people more
than our own age
generation, but we do.
So I feel like that's
the solidarity of that.
And really that -- and
with music, it's sort of --
once you're old enough
to kind of play in bars,
you're like all the same age,
depending on where you are
and the music you love.
So we can be we're, you know,
young people in our 20s and 30s,
but we're -- I see -- I
look at Ken and Jeanie,
who are into their
later years of life,
and it's like, we're the same.
It's just they're a little
further down the road
or something, you know.
I don't know, what
do you think, Jordan?
>> Jordan Wax: I was thinking
about the radicalism
from older musicians.
I think about like --
and getting to work with older
fiddle players in Missouri
and Mexican musicians and
musicians in New Mexico,
there's a lot of ideas that
we just have as a society
about what the musicians
are, what they're doing,
what the traditions
are, what cultures are.
And music's a wonderful
thing because the people
who are practicing it
often in a really deep way
and a committed -- you know,
the level of like lifetimes
of commitment and generations of
commitment, they don't have --
they don't share
any of those ideas
about what the divisions are
and what the purpose
of it is oftentimes.
And so I feel like there's --
I've had a chance to see where
there's society is saying, well,
this is who the musicians are
and this what they represent,
this is what they do.
And the musicians are
like, no, we're not that.
We have our own story.
And I think also, that ties
into that cross-cultural
level for me.
I'm not New Mexican.
And I think a lot of people --
you know, that's a
really interesting element
and experience of the band,
because a lot of people,
you know, will reject
that at first.
They'll say, well, you know,
this guy's an outsider
singing this music,
then it must be bad, you know.
But then there are people who
actually listen and they say,
oh, that's our music, that's
it, you guys are doing it well.
And I think working with
musicians and coming
from that experience where I've
had a chance to work with people
of lots of different
cultural backgrounds,
that maybe that brings
it out even more.
But people are always telling
me, oh, this, you know --
there's always been
this connection.
Or, you know, these musicians
from the Midwest came
and they shared this,
and you can hear
that in the older recordings.
And then, you know, working
with Seta Feni [phonetic]
and Mita Konda [phonetic],
saying, oh,
this musician came from here.
And this Texan musician who we
always listen to, he said, oh,
he was actually from
mitwakon [phonetic].
And there's been a lot of
exchange always going on.
But I think as things
move forward and we --
I don't know, it seems like
sometimes there's a tendency
to reduce the diversity
of the traditions and come
up with a simpler
and simpler idea.
And that gets reduced out and
people come up with one story,
that this is the people who
play this music, and this is --
and it just represents
this, you know,
a simpler form of identity.
And I think that the
example the older musicians
and how they express something
so much more complex helps
me a lot in dealing with that
and realizing, oh, actually
being complex and being diverse
and telling people, yeah,
you might have an idea
of how it's supposed
to be, but here we are
and we're obviously
something different.
It takes a little bit of a
radical or rebellious attitude
to I think to be able to believe
in ourselves and say like, yeah,
it is a little different than
people might be expecting,
but this is the best we can
do to maintain the continuity
and express that and renew
the tradition in the context
of our lives and be authentic.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah.
I think that creative pursuits
allow us to extrapolate
from an individual
to a larger idea.
And so as Jordan is saying
and as Noah has said,
like we're kind of
bridging I think a point
between what [inaudible],
who can put on one identity,
which is New Mexican, and
can put on another identity,
which is American, and
another identity which is
like college educated,
and, you know,
all of these different
forms of our identity,
that I'm using each of
these identities also
to further complicate
and sort of --
yeah, complicate
what's coming to me
from my background
or from my history.
And so in this way
I believe that music
and art are really
radical pursuits,
because all of our histories
are similarly bridged
by an individual.
And so we have a story
of our living together
as different groups of people
and as we identify differently,
either based on -- you know,
my mom being from the west side
and my dad from the east side,
though they're both Hispanic.
Or, you know, we're from New
Mexico and they're from Texas,
though we both love ranchera.
Or, I'm from New Mexico
and you're from Mexico,
but we're connected through
this string band style
which New Mexican
musicians can play I guess,
because we're doing that.
But there's not really a hard
or fast line about like, well,
Jordan's from Missouri, so
he can't possibly know how
to play New Mexican music.
Like Jordan knows how to
play New Mexican music.
Or Noah's from Albuquerque,
so he can't possibly know
how to play blues music.
Like Jordan's from -- I mean,
sorry, Noah is from Albuquerque
and absolutely is
a blues musician.
And so it's easy when we're
looking at a whole group
of people to simplify
these things,
and it's much more difficult to
look at a whole group of people
and to see individuals.
And that's the spirit that I
think I find in this group,
is that, you know,
certainly we're very concerned
about the tradition and we're
very concerned about speaking
with elders and we're
very concerned
with doing everything
in the right way.
But we're also members of our
generation in 2018 in America,
which also means we've been
exposed to the Internet.
We've had to use the
Internet a lot for research.
You know, I know what it's like
to hear music from East Asia,
which neither of my
parents had ever known.
And so even though we might
be sort of consciously --
we have these conscious
touchstones
which are northern New Mexico
fiddle tradition, you know,
Texas fiddle tradition,
and accordion tradition
and conjunto tradition
and muthican [phonetic].
Like I also play based
like I have extensive
African percussion training.
And that comes into play.
You know, it's changed
the way that I hear.
And so I'm hearing as a
person whose also learned
to hear differently based on
what I've been exposed to.
And as, you know,
members of this world,
which is tending toward
that way, tending toward
like blurring of lines,
it's important for me too
to say like, that's
part of the radicalism.
That I can be a person who
has studied West African music
and knows a very tiny, tiny,
tiny bit about what that's like.
And can say that I'm both,
and I'm also playing this
New Mexican tradition.
And so that's some of what
people are hearing too.
Though, as Jordan says, maybe,
you know, like at first glance,
it's easy to think,
oh, it's just this.
>> And I think it's --
from experiencing
with the elders too,
I think they were
always like that.
And they just had
different lives.
And, you know, in 1920 in rural
New Mexico, you're exposed
to a much different
palette of things.
And the musicians in Missouri
who, you know, they were exposed
to swing music and bluegrass
music and country music
and jazz and classical music.
And the best examples,
the masters of that
tradition, took from everything.
And we can look back and say,
oh, they're this one thing,
but they actually were --
their process was very creative
all along and very diverse.
>> Noah Martinez: Yeah.
And I think we can continue that
now I think with like thinking
of like touching back on what
Jordan and Leticia were saying,
yeah, we're not your
conventional New Mexican band.
And like I look at me,
like this is where I love
to be musically,
with these guys.
And it's always new and we're
moving forward constantly
and there's always the look down
the road is so invigorating,
I want to go really far.
Where I haven't had
that in the past.
And so when people look at us,
especially before
Leticia joined --
we had another guy
who was an Anglo guy.
And people in my community would
kind of judge us and be like,
oh, you're playing with those
gringos over there, huh.
Well, that's not real music.
And you're like, well, it kind
of is, because if I was waiting
around for a bunch of Chicanos
to play in a band with,
I'd be at home right
now, you know,
waiting to get off my shitty job
so we could go play at the VFW.
And that's as far
as it would go.
And we'd practice once
a week and that's it.
But because you have to take
those things away from it
and be like, well, because I am
a musician and I've always --
I just see the musician
as the musician.
I don't care about race, age,
color, sexuality, anything.
It's just you're a
musician, you're awesome.
You have this.
You study music.
You love it.
So we have that with each other.
So it really doesn't matter.
Even if we decided
tomorrow, like we don't want
to play this music
anymore, let's, you know,
let's do a different traditional
style that we're going
to get into, I think we'd
still have the same result
as a passion for the music,
because we love music.
At the end of the day,
musicianship doesn't know any
of those prejudices, it's just
who you are and what you love.
And I think this group's a
perfect example where it's
like Jordan's -- you
know, we all three
as individuals have very
different lives and come
from different places.
And we don't always come
together in the easiest way
because of that like, you know.
Because like Leticia, she grew
up one way, I grew up one way,
Jordan grew up one way.
But at the end of the day,
it's those differences
that we're forced to
settle that help us grow.
I know it helps me grow and
all of us, and we're all
in this thing together.
And if that's not more of an
example of just what growth is
and unity and -- like being here
in the nation's capital is like,
wow, this is the -- and hearing
all the different languages.
And it's like we're doing
exactly what we should be doing
and not thinking small-mindedly
and drawing circles
around what our picture
should be.
You know, it's totally free and
open, and I think that helps us.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah.
I think having the
external goal, you know --
and it's tangible, you know.
You pick up your instrument and
like we have to find some way
to be on the same page enough
to play this at the same tempo,
at the same rate, in the same
key, you know, hitting the verse
and then the chorus
at the same time.
Like that -- I don't think
that it's possible to ask
that we always grow or we always
like understand another person.
I mean, I think in the best
case scenario that happens.
But, you know, like
to be able to be
with each other in
our differences.
I think having music in a
creative pursuit in a way,
you know, like it's
a flexible thing.
You can say like, okay,
well, this is not working.
It's not working for us to play
this section two times here.
Because it's creative,
literally we can decide, well,
we're only going to do it once.
And that feels better for us.
Like we've been struggling with
gusteaus [phonetic] recently.
And for months and
months, it was like,
why is this gusteaus
not coming together?
Why is this not working,
you know?
Like we're listening to
the source recording,
we're doing what they're doing.
Are we going too fast?
Are we going too slow?
We tried it a million
different ways
and then we finally decided, for
whatever reason, it just needed
to be a little bit shorter.
And so, like, there's
that freedom and there's
that flexibility in order to,
like, to spend the time asking,
well, what's not
working, you know?
So whatever our backgrounds are,
you know, like, I had one idea
about why it wasn't working
and I'm sure these
guys had other ideas
about why it wasn't working.
That it matters but
it's secondary to, like,
we want to play this tune.
We love this tune and we love
this tradition and we just have
to kind of keep going
long enough
and to take enough pressures
away to understand that, like,
actually what the
music wants is this.
>> And if we can just
find a way to communicate
with each other that's
healthy for everyone,
we don't lose this beautiful
thing that we want --
all of us want so badly.
So that's been great.
That's really a lot of -- good.
>> Michelle Stefano: I must
say, you've touched upon
so many questions I
wanted to ask, thank you.
>> We're good at just going.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Yeah, it's a breeze.
But I'm going to back up
a little bit, if I may.
But you remind me of what
you, Leticia, said on stage
about polka -- I the think
the song was The Woman
Through Warsaw.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Oh yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
how, you know, the grabbing
of these traditions
and also the migration
of cultural knowledge, people.
Could you talk a little bit
about why polka is
in New Mexico?
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah.
So that tune actually
is a varsoviana,
which is not quite
a polka, so polka --
they're similar though, right?
So they're -- they're both
coming from Western Europe.
And so the polka tradition
overlays another tradition,
a lot of which we've lost.
So we have some dances that
are still danced in New Mexico
that are kind of more
directly from Spain,
one being the inditas, which
came over to Mexico and then
up the trail to New Mexico.
And so, inside of that, because
these are community dances
and because you can dance
them within certain rules
and regulations with
people -- other people --
so like, women and men dance
together, women dance with,
you know, their father
or their husband
or their brothers
or just changing.
Then when the American
colonies started moving west
and when soldiers were coming
-- before the soldiers,
there were other
Americans coming.
And those Americans brought
trumpets and they brought a lot
of different instruments
and they brought the polka.
And the New Mexicans,
for some reason,
probably because they were used
to community dances,
loved the polka.
So they grabbed onto the polka
and with the polka came the
varsovienne, which is a dance,
like, I don't know what
it's like in Warsaw.
It's probably not even
danced in Warsaw anymore.
Maybe it's not from Warsaw, it's
just about a woman from Warsaw.
That traveled all the way
from, you know, central Europe
through western Europe across
the ocean to the eastern part
of the United States,
and then over the trails,
you know, to New Mexico.
And New Mexicans loved it.
They were, like, we get this.
This makes sense to us, the
varsovienne, let's do it.
I don't listen to
a lot of pop music
so I can't find a pop,
like, parallel but.
>> Michelle Stefano:
The Macarena?
>> Leticia Gonzales:
Yeah, like the Macarena.
It's like the Macarena
of, like, the 1800s.
And it survived, probably
because it's so specific
and then also because
of the adaptations
that Jordan was mentioning
earlier, right?
Like we went from
fiddles to accordions
and then fiddle and accordion.
And then, you know, as
you could amplify things,
as dances were getting bigger,
as there were more people,
as our community
spaces were changing,
we started amplifying things.
And that turned into what
it's turned into now.
So like the polka, I see
a big, like, I don't know
that it is necessarily
related but the polka
and in the ranchera, which
is generally played amplified
and with guitars and stuff,
which is what my parents grew
up dancing, like, well, you
can dance the same dance
to a polka and to a ranchera.
I don't know if that answers
your question, I think it does.
>> Michelle Stefano: Absolutely!
That's very true.
>> Noah Martinez: Also, when
Jordan was doing research
in Mexico this past December,
he found out from Don
Serafinivara [phonetic]
that a lot of those tunes
are related to other songs
because he sent me a
version of a varsovienne
that Serafin [phonetic] does and
that they come from [inaudible]
and it's even deeper than that.
So somewhere when that --
along that line when it stopped
in Mexico it grew there
and a seed was planted
and then it came up -- zip.
But that tree's still
been growing so.
>> Jordan Wax: And that was
interesting to see too, like,
a lot of the style in
New Mexico, the waltzes,
like a waltz we played today
at the concert that comes
from [inaudible], and he learned
it from his uncle, [inaudible].
But in muchican [phonetic],
I heard some musicians
playing ritual funeral music,
and it was that exact tune,
with an extra third
section thrown in.
So I was like -- it was amazing.
And I was asking some of the
musicians, and they said, yeah,
I think that a lot of the really
old repertoire from Europe
that came over, these
waltzes, then were adopted.
And they're called minuetes
[phonetic], and muchican use
for funerals and
religious observances.
But then in New Mexico, they
were adapted into social music.
And that could be part
of why, or who knows why.
But that's one -- you
definitely hear it
and it's the same
tune, you know.
>> I was thinking
of another one,
but I lost my train of thought.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Well, since we're here
at the American Folklife
Center, which houses one
of the largest cultural
archives in the world,
would you talk a little bit more
about your archival research
or the work you do
with archives?
You mentioned the
University of New Mexico.
>> Yeah. GD, John
Rob [phonetic] --
which is crazy for me because
as a kid growing up, we were --
my grandpa's a farmer.
And we -- where I live
on the Rio Grande Valley
and North Valley of Albuquerque,
at one time there was just
fields and fields and fields.
We grew alfalfa and lots of
hay, different types of hay.
And now they're all
mansions mostly.
But as a child, we grew
up in those fields
working and working.
So I always remember
talking about,
we're going to do
the John Rob field.
Well, this was this John Donald
Rob, his home, his estate.
We farmed that --
I've been farming
that field my entire life.
And so when Jordan introduced me
to the collection, I was like,
John Donald Rob, this is --
something is ringing a bell,
I don't know why, but I didn't
-- they weren't together.
And then I was talking
with his daughter,
who now runs his estate at
his house, and she was talking
about her father and
being an archiver
of musicians, and
it all clicked.
And you're like, wow, what
a crazy connection that is
that you're so close
in the realm of, yeah,
you're literally working --
you're doing fieldwork and now
here I am studying the field
recordings of this
guy that he made.
So it's a good connection
for me.
And then the Juan B
Ryell [phonetic] stuff.
And a lot of -- Ken and
Jeanie did a lot of --
from Bayou Seco did
a lot of cataloging.
We found a recording
recently on a trip
down there that blew our minds.
And it's New Mexican musicians
playing pasodovas [phonetic],
which we haven't heard
ever in this region.
>> Yeah, we thought
that it didn't exist.
>> So yeah.
I mean, the other -- what
are some of the other?
>> Yeah, those two,
the one [inaudible]
and the John Donald Rob
were both available online.
So we've had a chance
to get a lot from that.
But then a lot has also been
from just personal relationships
of people who have had, oh,
this tape that they put on CD.
Our friend Thomas
really helped with that.
And he had a lot of recordings
of his uncle Antonio Reverra
[phonetic] and the bands
that he played with in
Santa Fe and some musicians
around peko [phonetic].
So kind of other
musicians have really --
older musicians have helped a
lot and saying, oh, here's this.
And just like last -- I guess
in the spring, that Jason
and Cordelia -- are some
older musicians and dancers.
And I had gone by their
house or something.
And they said, oh, look,
and they had this CD --
record, LP, of [inaudible]
from peko that I'd never heard.
And that's where we got some of
the tunes we did today as well.
>> So another one was we did
posobolo [phonetic] off the CD.
Our friend David Garcia up
in Espanola, he gave us a CD
that just said San Antonio
Trio, and it was bajo,
violin, and electric bass.
And we had no information
other than that,
but we just studied
that record forever.
And we made some contacts
with some people in Texas
who provided us with
information eventually.
We now know what that is.
But a lot of it's like
that, just stuff by chance.
And [inaudible], another guy
in New Mexico, who'd done --
he wrote a book and put a CD
collection of music out of tunes
and the people who played
them back in those days.
But YouTube a lot.
You know, I mean.
>> For Mexican stuff.
Oh, yeah, mostly musicians
I guess has been our main
inspiration of sources of music.
>> Michelle Stefano: You also
sing in different languages.
Can you talk about the
many different languages,
your repertoires
that you represent?
>> Yeah. We have a couple
songs in nywat [phonetic],
which is the language from
the Wastaka [phonetic].
So a lot of the ritual
music there which a lot
of it is kanarios
[phonetic] style.
And a lot of them have lyrics --
not many, but there are several
that have lyrics in nywat.
And so when I was down
there, I had some lessons
and was working on
learning that.
And then also some of the
music we played today I learned
from [inaudible].
And he's from Eutupia
[phonetic] Michoacan.
And their family speaks
porepicha [phonetic].
And so he helped me
with some of that.
And that's a beautiful
repertoire of porepicha music
that includes sonjos
alajenos [phonetic],
which are dance tunes
that are instrumental,
and them piedecuas
[phonetic], which are love songs
that are sung in porepicha
and sometimes Spanish.
And sometimes they're adapted
into fast-paced sones
[phonetic],
so you can sing with
those as well.
>> Leticia Gonzales:
We're lucky to have lyrics
in nywat and porepicha.
Because a lot of those
songs have been adapted
to Spanish, right.
So it's more common to
find -- I don't know.
I can't say that's true
for the porepicha music.
But huapangos, it's
much more common
to hear a huapango in Spanish.
So when we do have nywat
lyrics, it's pretty.
And I mean, there are certainly
bands that are doing that.
But at least in the
United States,
until I started diving
deeper into this music,
I didn't hear very many.
>> And it's cool they
do it in New Mexico
because they actually
were a lot of --
the [inaudible] people
who came up
and like built a
lot of Santa Fe.
And I don't know how many
generations that lasted.
But I mean, there's no
continuity of that now.
But it's cool to get to sing
in that language in a place
where it was once spoken.
>> We've also met some people
who are native language speakers
in Albuquerque that -- you know,
we would've never been able
to make those connections
without the repertoire.
And we met a family,
the Garcia family.
Remember those guys?
>> Yeah.
>> And they invited us back to a
party at their house and played.
It was a birthday party.
It was amazing.
Remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> It was so incredible.
>> The kinsonero [phonetic].
>> The kinsonero, yeah,
it was a kinsonero.
And yeah, just language --
having that language and the
fact that Jordan's been able
to research that, opened us --
it invites you into
more people's lives
and just gives a
more connections
with those folks there.
Really cool.
>> And it's cool too
I think because --
like we were talking
about, the radicalism
of representing a more
complex cultural picture
when people are expecting
something.
I think in New Mexico,
we're guilty of having
like an oversimplified
picture a lot of times.
Like the cowboys and
Indians and the Mexicans.
Which is not a very
useful model anymore.
But it still kind of persists
in the psyche or the culture.
And I think when people see this
band that is playing, you know,
Spanish music and they bring
all these associations with it,
and then they hear another,
an indigenous language,
that obviously is very
intimately connected
with the music.
It's fun to do that because I
think it instantly switches the
way people are watching
us and their expectations
and what they were thinking.
>> Leticia Gonzales: Yeah, it
definitely complicates things.
And I wanted to say
a little bit --
I've used archives especially --
I grew up hearing a
lot of religious songs.
So a lot of my musical
background
with elders was in church.
So Catholicism is
very predominant
in Hispanic communities
in New Mexico.
And I grew up very Catholic.
And I started using -- like
my favorite way to look
at archives is not only
to hear these recordings
but to see the different like
variations in lyrical content,
depending on where
that's being sung
or where it's being practiced.
And so in addition to music
being a social thing, it also --
I think one of the most
beautiful traditions
in New Mexican music is
the elobo [phonetic],
which is the song prayer.
And so everybody has a different
way of singing the same elobo.
And these lyrics are
really an amazing way to key
into different symbolic or
like psychological aspects
of the New Mexican --
greater New Mexican --
you know, the Catholic culture
in New Mexico, which survives
to this day, you know, in
sort of a different way.
And so I think, as Jordan
is saying, you know,
I think our cultures,
they kind of --
they get very like
very firm and fixed.
And then sometimes if you're
lucky, you're in a project
that gets to go back
in there and kind
of excise different things.
And we're like, wait,
this is what ended
up being fixed this way,
and this is what ended
up being fixed this
way, but they each come
from different places.
And the archives are a
really amazing way to kind
of find those different pieces.
It's like doing cultural
surgery kind of I think.
>> Yeah, that's a
great way to put it.
>> Yeah. And they kind
of preserve diversity
that didn't survive to our day
for us to get to experience.
You can look back and say like,
wow, look at this broad spectrum
of how this one tune
was being played.
And so I don't have to --
you know, I can learn
it from this one --
this version that one
particular fiddler played.
But my understanding doesn't
have to be limited to that
because I can hear all
these different ways,
incorporate different elements.
And I think that helps
create a lot of space
and breathing and
new life in it.
Because yeah, I think with
just the pieces of continuity
that we have -- I mean,
it works together.
And I think we didn't
know living musicians
who we could work
with personally,
the archives wouldn't be
worth very much to us,
or wouldn't be very useful.
But having those
two things together
to understand the
musicians and their examples
and how they play, and then
these different examples of,
you know, just recordings
in moments in time,
I think those things
can work together.
>> Noah Martinez: Yeah, and I
think, like Jordan was saying,
you have such a spectrum
to learn from.
It helps us because there's --
not anymore I don't feel
like we have it just
because we stopped
caring about it.
But in the beginning there was
such a pressure to do it right,
because we're these young,
nontypical-looking people
doing this traditional music
who aren't exactly
from the tradition.
Like I'm from New Mexico,
hard-core New Mexican,
but I'm from Albuquerque.
So when you go anywhere
north of there,
they're like, oh,
he's a city boy.
This guy doesn't know anything.
Go back over there.
And the same with all of us.
We're not -- we're
not from small,
northern New Mexican towns where
we know everybody and we walk in
and everyone knows us.
>> Leticia Gonzales: It wasn't
directly transmitted to us too,
like I didn't have
a dad who was like,
here's the whole New Mexican
fiddle tradition -- go.
>> And it gives us
that space to say,
here are all these different
people who've done this who are
to us bona fide musicians.
It's like, well we're
in there too, you know?
We bring all of what we do too.
One of our favorite guitar
players, Augustine Chavez,
he does all this amazing
licks and kind of swingy runs
because he was probably an
elite guitar player at his time,
learning from everything
that he could.
So that helps -- it helps give
us a breadth of not just --
here's this one recording.
If you don't play this polka
with a boom-chick, boom-chick
and do this run exactly and
do an upstroke, you're wrong.
It's kind of like,
well, it gives us space
and helps us have our own spot
to stand and be who we are.
>> And also in like all the
different styles we play,
it's cool to be able to
look back at these --
you know, a lot of the
archives come from --
like they start around 1950.
And it's cool to say like,
we're exposed to all this
because of YouTube and
because we can travel.
You know, you can buy a ticket
for 200 bucks to Mexico City.
And then you look back in
the 1950s, these musicians,
they also were doing
some huapangos
and they were also
doing woletos [phonetic]
and [inaudible] and
the same things.
And realizing, oh, the
different strands of cultures
that are intersecting and
interweaving in our lives today
that it feels so novel and
it feels like it's happening
in a novel way, but those same
things have been combining
for a long, long time and
just a different style
and different timescale
and different, you know,
level of technology and stuff.
But a lot of the same things.
I know that feels good to --
I don't know, reinforces that.
I think maybe something
that disempowers continuity
and traditions is people feeling
like, oh, I'm not that anymore.
I'm too different, so I
can't really participate
or be involved in that.
>> Modernism.
>> Yeah. It's like I'm
modern and that's not.
Those people are all
kind of other to me now.
But I think being able to see
that and really relate to that
and realize like, oh, no,
actually we are the same
as them, we're just
our generation
of the same people
that keep, you know.
>> Yeah. And for
us on that end now,
we are a hard-core folk band.
Like we -- today for
us doing sound check
with the microphones was
like the most anxiety
I've ever had in a gig.
Because we don't use microphones
-- we use one microphone,
you stand in front of it.
Here you go.
Here's your ham and
cheese sandwich,
move along down the line.
And today was like gourmet.
We're like all these
things and positioning.
And that's pretty
difficult for us.
But we just got booked
recently to play a festival
up in Talce [phonetic],
New Mexico.
And every group are electric
music computers, all this --
and we're on the
same bill as them.
So we're so extreme of being
a traditional folk band,
that we're now cool with
the electronic kids.
It's crazy.
When I saw that flyer, I was
like, wow, that is so unique.
So maybe there's more
of that turn is coming.
>> Michelle Stefano: Well,
you're on your way
to Brooklyn soon.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We're excited.
So yeah, it's just
kind of those --
it's those moments
where you go, whoa.
And then, you know, you
think we're going to be doing
that electronic music festival,
it's going to be
totally different for us.
And then we just had this great
week of music with Bayou Seco,
who learned from all the
elders and are just --
those two worlds
are so far apart.
And Lone Pinon's right
in the middle, you know.
So we're pretty lucky, man.
It's kind of cool.
It's pretty nice.
>> As far as just on the other
side of that, how people --
our generation don't
necessarily want
to associate themselves
with the old ways.
Because everything is growing
so rapidly and we're all trying
to keep up and move forward.
So it's nice when you move
forward by just standing still.
It's pretty good.
>> Michelle Stefano: So do
you feel like you're a bit
of a counterpoint these days?
>> Maybe.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Pushing back against.
>> I don't think maybe
people view us that way.
I don't feel like that's
like an objective for us.
Or maybe it's just something
that sort of happens naturally
and we don't recognize it.
>> Michelle Stefano: Right, like
the radicalism you were talking
about just by the nature
of playing what you play?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I think that's kind of.
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> No.
>> I was thinking -- hearing
you say that made me think,
a lot of the reason
why the tradition
in New Mexico started
being silenced, you know,
it wasn't anybody's mistake,
it wasn't people didn't care.
But it was like the
whole structure
of how we live together and the
economy and our society changed,
and the way people
were doing music
and this music no longer fit.
And so it just.
>> Went away.
>> It juts went away.
And so for us to say, no,
we're going to do that now,
it is like against the stream.
>> Like the pants are too small
but we're going to
make them fit.
>> Yeah. [inaudible].
>> Yeah, we got to
stretch them out.
>> Michelle Stefano: Just
going back a little bit.
You know, you've ben meeting
with so many master musicians,
become friends, this community
that you're also helping
to reconnect or strengthen.
Do you record anyone at all?
Are you secret folklorists?
>> I do, yeah.
>> I have a digital recorder.
And yeah, when I was visiting
saraphine [phonetic], I would --
every time he just
loved [inaudible].
And he was an Encyclopedia of
many generations of stories.
And I would always
just put that on.
And I'd send them back.
And I've got hours and hours
of him just talking
and telling stories.
And that was amazing.
Because, you know,
like one thing
that really impressed
me was we were talking
about this fiddler
[inaudible] from San Antonio.
And he was -- [inaudible]
re-released some
of his recordings.
And like on the description on
the back of it, they said, oh,
he's this rural fiddler
from south Texas
and people liked his music
because it was so rustic.
And then I was talking to --
and that he lived in San Antonio
and they lost track
of him or something.
And this fiddler [inaudible]
was like, [inaudible].
Yeah, we hung out all
the time in Mexico City
when he was an old man.
Yeah, he moved back
to Mexico City.
And I was working as a musician
there and I would always go
to his house and hang out.
And it was this whole
piece of the history
that wasn't known in America.
And he was actually, no, he
wasn't a rural Texas fiddler
at all, he was from Quiwila
[phonetic], and he played
in the symphony down here.
And yeah, he played a really
sophisticated style of music.
And it's cool, like that
really made an impression.
He was like, whoa, what was
printed on the back of the CD.
>> Michelle Stefano: Was wrong.
>> Was wrong.
And like the musician told me.
>> I love Jordan's
-- hearing Jordan.
He was gone and I was at home.
I had a little newborn at home
that I was taking care of.
And so when those
messages would come in,
they were like a saving grace
to me of musical knowledge.
And for us, you know, we've
done gigs and sat and been
on the ride home and like
just talked about, well,
how do you think
that this happened?
And why did this -- why is there
a [inaudible] in south Texas?
And I remember one of
the interviews was --
or one of the clips Jordan sent
me was him asking Saraphine.
He's like, oh, I knew the
guy that took the first one
over there, in San Antonio.
Yeah, [inaudible] all the time.
I knew him.
We're like, oh my goodness.
To have that source of all
the knowledge and everything.
And now, well, we
have it a little
so we can share the
stories about.
Yeah, that's pretty
nice to have.
>> Yeah. And I think
it's inspired me.
Just like now that -- I started
doing that with musicians
and the older musicians.
And as time's gone on,
now I've lost those people
and they've passed on,
and having those
recordings is so amazing.
And so now I record
not just musicians,
I record all kinds of people.
>> Yeah. I better
watch what I say
in the tour card
because I've always.
>> Yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano:
There are codes of ethics.
>> Yeah. I don't have to
follow any of them in my life.
It's just like at
family gatherings
and stuff, I'll just put it on.
>> You never know.
>> It's like -- yeah,
music's just like anything,
that moment will never repeat
of having those people together
and that they were all in
that phase of their life.
And I have recordings of my
grandma singing in a way that --
she'll still thing but
not like she used to.
And so I have those recordings.
And that it means a lot to me.
So yeah, I'm a secret
folklorist.
Probably unethical.
>> Leticia Gonzales:
It's not secret anymore.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Welcome to YouTube.
>> Yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano:
This has been wonderful.
Thank you so much.
I guess my last question would
be, what's next for Lone Pinon?
>> Lunch. I'm just kidding.
>> Leticia Gonzales:
We already had lunch.
>> Oh yeah.
Second lunch.
I don't know, just try -- I
guess for me it's like just try
and keep it -- try and keep all
the wheels turning, you know.
Life catches up with us outside
of music, and it makes it hard.
You know, just to be
honest, it's difficult
to keep going with everything.
So for us, it's just -- for me,
it's like just keeping it
alive is the next thing.
And then after everything will
come, we'll follow from there.
>> Leticia Gonzales: We
do have a couple projects
that we're working on.
So we've recorded an
album called [inaudible],
which should be released --
I don't know if we
decided it was going
to be this fall or
in the spring.
But upcoming.
And then we're working --
we've gotten a grant from the
John Donald Rob Foundation
to record specifically
New Mexican tunes.
So we're also going to hopefully
get into the studio and record
with some of the elders.
Those as well.
Because the other
albums have, you know,
been kind of a collection
of all of the traditions,
and we don't have anything
that's just the New
Mexican style.
So that's some more archival
work that'll be upcoming.
> Yeah, that'll be a lot of fun.
>> Yeah. It's going to be great
to have the opportunity
to do that.
>> Yeah. And just trying to --
like we got that
little that grant,
which will partially help.
We don't have enough
for the rest,
so if anyone's watching this
and would like to [inaudible].
But yeah, I mean, that is
kind of the situation a lot.
Like Noah said, it's
tricky to keep it going.
And we've been doing
it full-time,
which is a real challenge.
And, you know, trying
to figure out --
a lot of what we've been
doing is trying to figure
out what's the -- like
what's the economic role
for a band doing this kind of
traditional music in New Mexico.
And also, thinking that if
we can create that space,
then it creates space not just
for us but for other musicians
to be involved in the tradition.
Because if no one can -- you
know, if no one can afford
to play this kind of
music, no one will.
And I think the hard work
we do hopefully will --
I know that's one thought
I've had, is that it could,
you know, create a space.
You know, like part of the
way the music went away was
because the economic
aspect of it was cut off.
>> Didn't allow it.
>> Yeah, didn't allow it.
And the way it fit
before didn't and trying
to find new ways to make it fit.
And so that is a tricky
element of what we do.
I'm not like militantly
attached to, you know,
all being full-time
and making that work.
But we do have to find a way
to make it work in our lives.
And it can be challenging
in our region.
Because, you know, there's
some good playing opportunities
and then we have to play in
a lot of bars and cantinos.
That, you know, after years
and years of doing that,
starting to say, well, maybe we
really don't want to do that.
And if we don't do that, how do
we keep up the band, you know?
>> And even just logistically,
we all three of us live
in different towns, you know,
within an hour of each other.
So it's like, you know, it
would be great to be, you know,
chummy 21-year-olds and
we all share a house
for $10 a month wherever
we can live.
But it's difficult, you
know, having a life,
trying to build a life that is
able to support music and try
and build music that's able
to support your life as well.
I think finding the balance
in there is kind of
a priority for us.
But we've done a pretty good.
I mean, even like I think
from the first days,
it was like we still kind
of have that taste of like,
this is awesome and let's
just as long as this lasts,
we're going to give it
our all and enjoy it
and get as far as we can.
And I still feel that.
Kind of like I still
feel those butterflies
like when we played today
that I felt when we first met,
you know, and like when
Leticia first came on with us,
and just the power that
we all have together.
And it's like, okay, we
can make this work I think,
just keep it going, you know.
That's the hard part,
keeping it going.
>> Michelle Stefano: All right.
Is there anything else
you'd like to add?
[inaudible].
All right, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.